Hello, I
'm Capcom Producer's Capcom Brown. I've been participating in the Legend table series
as a programmer at Table Zero for the first time in a while.
Now
I'm a producer and I'm a compensation finish.  Although it was a
cube version of Resident Evil, I have been involved in this series since I was involved as a designer at that time. With the
release of the first Resident Evil type in 1996,
the genre of video game survival horror was established.  I think that
fans still remember that Capcom, who was surprised and scared by walking in the dimly lit corridor
.  I am grateful that it remains in my
memories and that I cherish those memories
so much. I have
high expectations for the future development of the series, but on the other hand, I would like to share with you
the past works of the series.  We have received a lot of voices that we would like to play.
Especially with
regard to the remake version of the first work, resident evil, which was released in 2002, that voice
is a very loud
title
.  For fans, this time
we're playing the remake version of Regentable hd Master. It
will be released on PlayStation 3 xbox one x360 pc in early 2015.
This includes improved graphics and of course other updates.  In making the more and more
hd master version, we aimed to make the original play
experience hd, which is to value the atmosphere of the original
and sometimes choose not to change it.
Not only aiming for beauty, but also to express the atmosphere and atmosphere
of the
original, we
are doing the work of polishing one part of the original and carefully assembling it, and we are doing the first place or lower.
There is a fear that is generated by the calculated time.
An indispensable preference for composing that fear.
The remake version of the Legend Department's hd remaster,
which is being produced with the aim of creating a fig of the original play experience, paying
close attention to the choices that
do not change in order to
cherish  I hope everyone in Forfans will enjoy it. Also, I
will introduce the news about the series later, so
please pay attention to all the table channels on facebook. Thank
you for today. Thank you.